what if everything you thought you
knew about weight loss was a [Music]
lie hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
kitchen for decades we have known that weight loss
comes down to a simple equation of calories in
minus calories out that everyone just needs to
follow the simple laws of thermodynamics to have
an equal chance of losing weight well what if I
was going to challenge that assumption what
if 100 calories of chocolate had a different
effect on the energy equation than 100 calories
of broccoli what if the calories in an apple to
me were different than the calories in an apple to
you the math here just ain't going to math what So
today we're going to be doing a deep dive into the
health of our gut and answer the age-old question
is a calorie a calorie a calorie and a quick thank
you to Aaron Davis my Rd colleague for supporting
me on this don't forget to hit up my general
disclaimer including a reminder that this video
is not an encouragement or a suggestion to try to
lose weight or to manipulate calories I am simply
going to be answering a super interesting sciency
question that is consistently misunderstood in the
weight loss Community also don't forget to hit up
my description for my free Hunger crushing combo
ebook for some healthy meal and snack ideas
let me hop in here quick to tell you about
today's sponsor zbiotics I love all my sponsors
but rarely am I so excited that I would like
leap at the chance to buy shares in this company
that's how much I love it but if you haven't heard
me talk about this yet zbiotics is a probiotic
drink that you take before you drink alcohol to
prevent the rough morning aftermath this is the
world's first genetically engineered probiotic
invented by a team of PhD microbiologists that's
been specifically designed with this one job in
mind basically when you drink alcohol gets
converted into a toxic byproduct AED alahh
that's responsible for the rough next day zbiotics
produces an enzyme that breaks down that byproduct
in your gut this is no word of an exaggeration
but I have turned my entire friend Circle onto
these things by giving them out before dinner my
friends are now telling their friends about them
because we just cannot rally with our kids without
it now this is not an invitation to over andbe you
still need to drink responsibly stay hydrated
and of course get a good night's rest but this
absolutely helps me function the next day with my
kids so this Halloween you can pair your candy and
Cocktails with zbiotics to avoid a spooky next
morning if you know what I mean go to zbiotics
docomo Abby sharp at checkout you can
also sign up for a subscription using
my code so you can stay prepared no matter
the time or occasion zbiotics is backed by
100% money back guarantee so if you're
not satisfied for any reason they will
refund your money no questions asked
and don't forget to head to zbiotics
docomo for 15% off thank you again to zbiotics
for sponsoring this video okay so as I discussed
in my video right here weight loss efforts are
made a little bit complicated by a wide range
of compensatory mechanisms that our body throws
into high gear to maintain our homeostatic set
point weight I also went to detail into why
calorie counting isn't a precise science in a
very controversial video that got people really
riled up right here but as a little recap there
are several factors that influence our body's
calorie needs Beyond those that just go into
formulas or calculators that we have access
to online so things like muscle Mass climate
hormonal status weight history ethnicity and a
lot more there's also the thermic effect of food
and changes to the calorie count with chewing
and cooking not to mention the whole calorie
calculation is based on a ridiculously small
study and the research was thoroughly flawed
but further complicating this already very
complicated flawed science is the role of
our gut and that is what we're going to focus in
on today so we have ample research at this point
that links specific gut microbiome profiles
or characteristics to obesity and metabolic
syndrome in other words fat people's guts just
look different than thin people's guts we tend
to see specific bacterial species in the guts
of folks who are overweight and other species
that are found in folks who are lean with the most
prominent observation being that obese folks tend
to have high firm acutes to bacteria deaths
ratio so this High f2b ratio is one example
of gut dysbiosis neither of these bacterias
are necessarily bad but disrupting the ratio
is where we see some trouble but the question
is what comes first the bad microbiome or the
diet related obesity in other words is our diet
to blame for ruining our gut microbiome which
then becomes a marker of obesity or does our gut
microbiome inherently Destin us to obesity let me
go wash my hands and I will answer that question
for you several bad T later well honestly we
don't totally know but it's probably a little
bit of both so we know that genetics can alter
our gut microbiome and we also know that Mom's
gut microbiome can influence baby's microbiome
in utero as can breast milk in that first year of
life but if your mom had a bad microbiome or a bad
diet it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
destined to be overweight how we nurture our
own microbiome through diet is really key here
what we eat has a direct and important impact
on which bacteria species can grow and flourish
and fiber a prebiotics is the fuel that feeds the
good bacteria which is one of many reasons why
fiber is an integral part of my Hunger crushing
combo interestingly in contrast one review of the
literature found that peoples whose diets was low
in fiber and high in animal protein had guts
with a ratio of high bacteroids to low level
of firmicutes which is associated with IBD so no
the carnivore diet is probably not good for your
[Music] gut now another diet that might not be so
good for the gut depending on how you interpret
it is something like If It Fits your Macros now
obviously this could be done in a super balanced
gut friendly way but do you guys remember when
like fit Bros on Tik Tok and Instagram we're
promoting eating like poptarts and like little
Debbies for weight loss I mean this might work
just fine for some folks to some extent for a
certain period of time but it's certainly not
best practice for weight loss and we used to think
this was just because eating a food like Pop-Tarts
which is low in hunger crushing compounds simply
makes staying in a calorie deficit a little bit
more difficult because you're going to get hungry
but new research suggests that we may actually
absorb more calories from those Pop-Tarts
versus the equivalent number of calories
of apples or peas let me explain so a recent
2023 study proposed that a calorie is not just
a calorie it's not just about how many calories
are available to us it's about how many of those
calories that our body uniquely can use and absorb
and that depends on our gut so Ultra processed
foods like Pop-Tarts are quickly absorbed in the
upper gastrointestinal tract which means we can
kind of like squeeze more energy out of them but
higher fiber foods make their way into the large
intestine where bacteria kind of like await their
feast the bacteria can digest and absorb some of
those available calories leaving fewer excess
calories to be potentially stored as fat so our
body and our microbes are basically fighting over
this energy right [Music] and the more processed
the food the more likely we are to win and the
less likely we are to share with our microbes
rude right as my Justice obsessed 5-year-old would
say sharing means caring but anyways in this study
they gave one group a very fiber rich diet lots of
resistant starch fruits veggies beans whole grains
that was designed to make the microbes super
happy happy and then they gave the other group
a diet that was rich in Ultra processed foods
so things like a lot of white bread ground beef
American cheese cheese puffs cookies deli meats
Etc now this was a small study but super super
rigorous in design because the partipants had
to live in a metabolic Ward where every single
calorie was accounted for that's really hard to
do and it wasn't just the inputs that they were
controlling they were collecting the outputs
too AKA they were collecting everybody's poop
and when they looked at said poop they were able
to measure the Lost calories we'll call them the
lost boys so the fiber group lost on average 2117
calories per day while the processed food group
only lost about half of that and some people lost
around 400 calories in the fiber rich Group which
alone could create a calorie deficit resulting
in almost a pound loss per week so this likely
came down to the existing health and diversity
of each participants microbiome the more good
bacteria and the more diverse the party going
on down there the more calories they can Goble
up and if you're thinking well wouldn't losing
calories just like make you more hungry and want
to eat more actually no the study found that the
fiber group did not experience any increase in
hunger despite losing the fight for more of those
calories and that's not even the most interesting
part I know I'm geeking out here but stay with
me not only did the fiber group group not absorb
or utilize as many calories but feeding the gut
bacteria also produced short chain fatty acids and
increased levels of glp1 and if that term sounds
familiar it's because people are spending up to
$1,000 per month to inject themselves with this
to help suppress their appetite and help them
lose weight AKA OIC so this is like part of the
package deal when you eat more fiber it's truly
magical stuff and obviously as I said this is
a a small study and we need a lot more research
to confirm these findings on a much bigger scale
but it may offer some really interesting insights
into what we know about a predominantly Whole Food
plant-based high-fiber diet and weight management
so for example research has Associated a reduction
in short chain fatty acids which we just mentioned
with a higher risk of obesity so short chain
fatty acids are basically the byproduct of
bacteria fermenting resistant starches and
fibers that act as signaling molecules to reduce
appetite hormones like py and grin and increase
metabolism and calorie expenditure and research
is now exploring how fiber supplementation can
increase these short chain fatty acids in the
gut on a dose dependent basis to have all of these
potential weight management effects disbiosis is
linked with obesity and we know that our diet can
play a role in feeding the good bacteria to help
to correct this disbiosis while also feeding our
bacteria instead of our fat cells more calories
if that makes sense and all of this plays into
weight management so if you're like okay Abby
just tell me what to do here this next section is
for you so obviously it starts with diet that's
what we're here prebiotics and probiotics so
prebiotics are the bacteria food which as we've
established is predominantly fiber so dietary
fiber consensus recommends about 14 G per 1,
calories per day which is anywhere in the
neighborhood of like 25 to 38 G of fiber but
just like you might like broccoli and I might like
brussels sprouts different bacterial strains can
kind of be like picky about their preferred fuel
so if we want a diverse and plentiful microbiome
we need different fiber sources every fiber
promotes its own unique microbiotic action so
bacteroids like soluble fiber oats barley apples
Etc and like actino bacteria like insoluble fiber
so things like wheat bran or nuts Etc now
I think I've paded this enough let me wash
my hands and I'll tell you more a few minutes
later now probiotics are sources of the bacteria
themselves AKA fermented foods like sauerkraut
kombucha kimchi kefir yogurt Etc we also know that
probiotic supplements can help to restore that
optimal firmicutes to bacterio at ratio so the
most common study for this are the lactobacillus
and the basilla strains and sacchromyces yeasts
and while fiber can absolutely help you better
manage your appetite and hunger we do still want
to be mindful about overc consumption so one study
found that increase in calories from 2400 to 3400
increased the firmicutes by 20% and decreased the
bacterio debts by another 20% Which is the same
ratio associated with risk of obesity now exercise
can also modulate that bacteria by effectively
promoting bacterial diversity improving that
firmicutes to bacterio dats ratio increasing
the proliferation of bacterial species that can
improve gut barrier functions and stimulating
bacterial species that produce those short chain
fatty acids and remember those short- chain fatty
acids help to suppress hunger and improve
our metabolism so this is a very complicated
subject but I think that the solution is actually
quite simple add more high fiber Whole Foods to
your diet it's also a good reminder as to why
my Hunger crushing combo works over something
extreme or restrictive like keto or carnivore and
it encourages variety which as we've established
is really key to keeping our very diverse
microbiome happy and it also encourages to add
fiber which not only contributes to Sati because
of its ability to slow down digestion and flatten
the blood sugar curve but it also increases those
short chain fatty acids production which helps to
manage appetite if you're interested in other gut
health videos leave me a comment below because
I could geek out on this all day I'm going to
throw my baked French toast in the oven right
now and on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today thank you again to Aaron
Davis for research support on this one it was a
Dey I will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music] bye